the Joe Rogan experience how old you 30
you know you're very young in terms of
like someone who's gonna be President
yeah that's young how old was JFK when
he got elected I'm 41 yeah 42 olden use
I'm like that
barely oh I'll be 40 when I'm sworn in
sworn in his brother I write it right
around there okay but like I say when
but exactly in confidence look look at
look at Donald Trump though so what he's
in his mid-70s right
but his maturity is of an adolescent
he's cast he's he should have been a
communion I'm telling you the guy would
have been killing it comic instead of a
real estate developer yeah that's true
yeah he's very but my point is maturity
maturity matters
yes experience matters and that the
experience that I bring is is different
from any other candidate who's running
for president serving as a soldier for
16 years of serving in Congress on these
on these committees of importance and
national security
you know I've served the state
legislature and the City Council and
look when you look back we talked about
our founding fathers most of them who
crafted the Constitution and who wrote
the Declaration of Independence were
under the age of 40 many unpeopled you
live there you like 40 bagman still
still we're talking about experiencing
maturity here I know you're know you're
defending yourself I support you I think
you could be President 38 I really do I
don't think it's a problem yeah at 40
for sure you 24 years older or 24 months
older you're gonna be wiser you have it
but we do wonder right like how when has
a person had enough life experience and
what but then again the question is what
is that life experience is it life
experience like you said that leads you
to be an immature seven-year-old or is
it a life experience of someone who's
served in combat and has been on in
Congress for six years and someone who
understands how this government were
yeah has a better perspective of human
beings yeah it is it is that experience
and it's what you draw from it and the
conclusions and the judgment and the
kind of leadership that you would
exercise you know you know there were a
lot of folks in 2016 who said Hillary
Clinton was the most experienced
candidate ever to run for president
because of the jobs she had held or the
experience that she had had my problem
was with her judgment and the kinds of
decisions that she would make as
commander in chief decisions that would
continue to send people like me and my
brothers and sisters in uniform to
continue to fight in these wasteful
regime-change wars that actually
dishonor the oath that we all take when
we volunteer to serve to serve to
protect and defend our country and the
American people and instead sending us
on these missions that are counter to
that promise that undermine our national
scale that undermine the great sacrifice
that our troops and their families make
so it's that judgment it's the
experience and the judgment that I
believe we need to look for in the next
commander-in-chief it's what I bring to
the table and it's what I challenge
voters to ask the other candidates and
to to hold them to account on both of
those fronts would they be ready to walk
into that Oval Office on day one and to
serve our country as commander in chief